to dudy throw some David Le Roth at will
underrated impression now here's the
thing about that I don't need uh
dud okay to do a an impression this is
what I mean by free will do you
understand if I want to do an impression
I'll do an impression ain't that right d
That's Right champ give us some Diamond
Dave okay hey man uh uh you know a lot
of people want to know about the story
of the brown M&M's you know what I mean
and
hey it's a dirty rumor but it might be
true and who am I to get in the way of a
said rumor come on in sit down have a
seat make yourself comfortable humbl zbl
who gives a but you thought that was
Free Will what do you mean you got a
double command you got a command from
someone in the comment and then dudy
commanded you to do
that